[Music]  long ago the world was full of wonder it  was adventurous there was magic it  wasn't easy to master  so the world found a simpler way to get  by but I hope there's a little magic  left in you there dad said to give you  this when you were both over 16  it's a wizard step dad was a wizard your  dad was an accountant this spell brings  him back  what back like back to life that's not  possible it is with this I'm gonna meet  dad  dad 24 hours to bring the rest of them  back we're going on  [Music]  I think we should take the path a barrel  but these first ladies bastard the long  run fine dad gotta go  [Music]  there could be booby traps  before you cast a spell again you're  gonna have to practice elbows out feet  apart back looks like the house  oh yeah what we need spell that creates  a magical bridge you can walk on if you  believe the bridge is there then it's  there you can do this  [Music]